oh hello hey so I've been thinking a lot
about my defense I think mr. McCarthy
before we start I think we should wait
for my assistant Jen to join the call
issue are they I told her the number in
the conference code so she's gonna
probably be announced you know that
awkward like an ant or goes like Jen
Williams this isn't a conference call
let's just wait for kids it's impossible
to conference call it's a direct line
between you and me that's it just one
second though I'm getting another call
hello there's no call waiting thanks for
getting back to me I called about my
satellite dish yes I'm having a problem
my neighbor Eduardo he gave it a nudge
with a broom and now I'm only getting
Spanish channels could he send somebody
by give it a nudge with maybe one of
your brooms the other way yeah I know
no I can hold got me on hold there's no
hall there's no other line hmm this is
not hold music this is you singing
mm-hmm
Rod Stewart that is not Rod Stewart
that was not Rod Stewart I'm trying to
make work you didn't even know the
lyrics
they only give me a couple minutes to do
this okay you're right
okay let's discuss serious things
serious matters can we talk about my
case yes let's talk about your case I
actually think I had a big breakthrough
last night I think I might be able to
get you out of here in about him if we
several simple steps that it's going to
be very easy but you need to listen to
me carefully stop at bad connection cell
phone god damn 80 and you're just
spacing out words you're not even doing
a good job pretending you have a bad
connection sorry I'm going through a
tunnel
stop shop I'm sorry okay this is the
defense I want to use okay no please go
on I really want to hear your thoughts
on the case stop doing that
what no no please I'm all ears I really
want to hear your opinion as a
non-professional about this case I can
see you making faces I can see
everything that you're doing right now I
can see you making the little don't
worry I'm gonna get you out of here see
I can see you shake your head no dummy
this is two-way glass that means I can
see you but you can't see me like the
FBI you're wearing a gray jacket and
white shirt hey this has been one of
those gag voicemail greetings what do
you think you're talking to the person
but then I say please leave a message
please leave a message
you